This is Yoni.
He's from Honduras and sought asylum in Mexico
just days ago.
Next Monday, Yoni will pick up a certificate
to prove he has begun the process.
I went to the office for refugees and saw
that it's fairly straightforward.
I've even heard that some people already had
their IDs after five days."
With that official ID, they can work in Mexico
while their application is being reviewed.
Some companies even try to employ workers
at the office for refugees.
While there, Yoni had two job offers.
One of the jobs was in maintenance at Tijuana
International Airport and the other was working
for a restaurant chain here in Tijuana.
Yoni doesn't have enough money to pay a smuggler
to get him into the US, but he also doesn't
want to risk seeking asylum there.
After Sunday's clashes, some - like Besy - have
decided to stay in Mexico.
She saw the difficulty in getting across the
border and doesn't want to put her two daughters
at risk.
We're staying here because of the current
situation and because of all the obstacles
they're putting in our way.
We know Mexico is a dangerous country, but
I've left Honduras and have nothing there.
Why would I go back?
But it appears only a small percentage actually
want to stay in Mexico - just 7% of the caravan
migrants have sought asylum in Mexico.
This despite the large number of jobs the
regional government has offered, or the straightforward
asylum process.
Getting into the United States remains the
migrants' ultimate goal.
500 people have requested a visa on humanitarian
grounds.
Considering there are seven or eight thousand
people, it's not very many.
We believe that they might warm up to the
idea in the coming days, if they really are
escaping their home countries because they
are in danger there.
Around 1,700 other Central American migrants
have volunarily sought repatriation to their
homelands.
That number has tripled this week to 30 people
per day.
Some migrants, like Jorge, felt intimidated
by the US police's stance against the migrants.
The Americans aren't going to back down.
They're not going to open the gates.
What are we going to do here?
Nothing.
It's better that we go back to our home countries
and work there...even if we can't get much
work, it's better than being here."
The American dream is, for some at least,
just that...a dream too far-fetched to realise.